السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه الاثناء عواصم
ومدن في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث خاصه
البدايه من النيابه عاصمه النيجر حيث رفض
قاده الانقلاب السماحه لوفد ثلاثي تمثل
الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده بدخول
البلاد
والى
مع انطلاقه فعاليه قمه دول حوض الامازون
في مدينه بلم شماليه البرازيل لمواجهه
مخاطر ازاله الغابات ومنع وصول غابات
الامازون المطيره الى نقطه العوده
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
قبل يومين من قمتها في ابوجا تفرض عقوبات
على شخصيات وكيانات مرتبطه بانقلاب النيجر
رئاسه المجموعه تتمسك بعدم استبعاد اي
خيار للتعامل مع الازمه واشنطن تصف
مباحثات مفادتها الى النيجر بالصعبه
للغايه وتقول ان من غير الواضح ما اذا كان
قاده الانقلاب سيختارون المسار الدبلوماسي
في يوم شهد بعضا من اعنف المعارك في
السودان الجيش ينفذ ضربات للسيطره على جسر
استراتيجي بام درمان ويعلن والحاق ادرار
بالغه بالدعم السريع والدعم يقول انه حقق
مكاسب على محاور عده في المدينه والامم
المتحده تجدد تحضيرها بشان خطوره الوضع
الانساني في السودان
كيف تعلن تنفيذ عمليه انزال نوعيه على نهر
دنيبر في الجبهه الجنوبيه
وتتهم القوات الروسيه بقصف مباني سكنيه
شرقيه البلاد موسكو تنفي وتقول انها
استهدفت قياده العمليات هناك
وتؤكد امتلاكها ما يكفي من القوات
للانتصار في المعركه وتحقيق السلام
بشروطها
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم مالات التوتر على
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه وسط مخاوف
دفعت الجيش الاسرائيلي الى وضع سيناريوهات
لحرب محتمله وتوجيه تهديدات شديده اللهجه
على لسان وزير الدفاع
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي السؤال يقول
ما هي احتمالات تحول التوتر على الحدود
بين اسرائيل ولبنان الى حرب الاجابات جاءت
على النحو التالي قرابه ال 25% اعتبروا
احتمالات الحرب كبيره فيما ذهب نحو 26%
الى ان هذه الاحتمالات تبقى محدوده بينما
قال 49% انه لا يوجد احتمال لنسوب مثل هذه
الحرب اصلا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
سريعه هي التطورات والمواقف المتعلقه
بالنيجر بعد الانقلاب واشنطن تقول انها لا
تزال تامن بحل دبلوماسي هناك لكنها تبقى
واقعيه وقبل قمه مرتقبه الخميس اكواس تفعل
المزيد من العقوبات على قاده الانقلاب
وداعميهم لكنها لا تستبعد مع ذلك اي خيار
لحل الازمه حتى لو كان يعطي الاولويه
للمسار الدبلوماسيه وفي نيامي قاده
الانقلاب يرفضون استقبال وفدا دبلوماسيا
للتفاوض
هدوء مشروب بالحذر في عاصمه بلد تحت حكم
انقلاب عسكري بين داعم ورافض له وتحت
تهديد تدخل عسكري لاعاده النظام الدستوري
تحسبا للاسوء واستنادا لتقاريرا ينشر
المجلس العسكري قوات اضافيه حديث ايضا عن
جلب قوات من اجزاء اخرى من البلاد
استعدادا لمواجهه مسلحه
يبقى مجرد احتمال يكون احيانا واردا جدا
واحيانا اخرى مستبعدا خيارات اكواس الاولى
والاخيره كلها صعبه رفضت النيجر دخول وفد
ثلاثي من الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده
بررت اسباب قرارها في رساله الى ممثليه
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا في
نيامي وجاء فيها ان السياق الحالي من غضب
السكان واستيائهم من العقوبات التي فرضتها
ايكواس لا تسمح باستقبال الوفد المذكور في
اجواء هاد امينه في اجواء صعبه اجرت
مبعوثه الولايات المتحده فيكتوريا نولاند
محادثات لساعتين مع الجنرال مسلسلوبارمو
الذي عين رئيسا جديدا لهيئه الاركان وقاده
اخرين لقي طلبها لقاء عبد الرحمن تياني
الرجل القوي الان في البلاد والرئيسه
المحتجز بازوم رفضا مزدوجا قالت نولد
لاحقا انها عرضت عددا من الخيارات لانهاء
انقلاب مشيره الى ان قاده الانقلاب يدركنا
جيدا المخاطر التي تهدد سيادتهم عندما
تدعى فاجنر الى النيجر
فاجنر يتردد ويتكرر اسم المجموعه في اغلب
التصريحات المسؤولين الغربيين حذر وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي من لعب المجموعه دورا
بعد الانقلاب العسكري في النيجر اوضح في
احدث تصريحاته انه يعتقد بان ما حصل
ويستمر في الحصول في النيجر لم تح عليه
روسيا او فاقنر لكنهم يحاولون استغلاله
الحديث عن فرص الدبلوماسيه لانهاء ازمه
الانقلاب باقل الخسائر الممكنه يقابله في
الحقيقه تخبط في المواقف وانقسام داخل
البيت الافريقي ومخاوف تزداد من تدخل
عسكري قد يشعل حربا اقليميه في المنطقه
على موعد مع قمه استثنائيه اخرى الخميس
المقبل في ابو جان استبقت الحدث المنتظره
بعقوبات تتضمن حظر السفر وتجميد اصول قاده
الانقلاب العسكري وحلفائهم قاده امام
خيارين احلاهما مروا قبول على مضت لسابع
انقلاب عسكري في منطقه غرب ووسط افريقيا
خلال ثلاث سنوات ام الدفع بقوات غير
مستعده تماما لتدخل عسكري هو بحد ذاته
سيفجر ازمه اخرى
النيجر اي مصير ينتظرها ومن سيقرره وباي
ثمن سيكون
اكدت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا ان موقف بلادها على غرار موقف
شركائها في الاتحاد الاوروبي واضح حيال
محاوله انقلاب الجاريه
وسيظل كذلك
واضافه واضافت في رساله حصلت عليها
الجزيره ان فرنسا لا تعترف الا بالرئيس
محمد بازون المنتخب من الشعب النيجيري وفق
تعبيرها واضافت الوزيره الفرنسيه في ردها
على رساله سفيره النيجر التي عزلتها
السلطه العسكريه ان فرنسا لا تعترف باي
شرعيه لقرارات ومبادرات الانقلابي
انضموا الينا الان من نيامي كل من الدكتور
علي ابو بكر اماده الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي ومن ابوجا بول ايجي مي مسؤول
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه السابق في المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا المعروفه
اختصارا باسم شكرا للمشاركه نبدا بضيفنا
من نيامي دكتور علي ابو بكر
الى متى سيستمر الانقلابيون في رفض اي
قنوات حوار معه
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته السياسي
انقلابيون كما بينتم يعني يريدون ان
يبينوا للامه
للعالم كلها السبب الرئيسي الذي من اجله
قاموا بهذه هذا الانقلاب ولذلك هم مصرون
على ارائهم وسيزلون معها الى ان يروا ان
هناك مفاوضه التي تكون على صالحهم وما اظن
انهم سينقدوني بما يقوله الايقونات او بما
يفرضه عليهم نعم ولكن على ماذا يعاونون
تحديدا دكتور
الذي يعولنه هو الحاله الامنيه السيئه
الموجوده هنا وكذلك كما يقولون ايضا
الاله الاقتصاديه غير جيده وامور كثيره
والان الشعب تعاني اعانت وما زالت تعاني
ولذلك راوا ان لابد ان يكون هناك تغيير
لهذه الحاله السيئه التي نحن نعيشها ولذلك
هذا الذي هذا هو مبررهم لهذا الانقلاب
الذي قاموا به نعم اذا كانت الصوره بهذا
الشكل السيد في ابوجا
ما بامكان الاكواس ان تفعل الان
بالنسبه الى المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا يمكنها ان تنخرط في حوار مع
القاده العسكريين في النيجر من اجل
استحداثي ارضيه مشتركه يمكن العمل عليها
لان الانقلاب العسكري ليس
بالسبيل
الذي يمكن ان يدعم سواء كان من قبل الناس
في الشرق الغرب او في افريقيا هناك ثلاثه
بلدان في افريقيا شهدت انقلابات عسكريه
والان اتى دور النيجر ولذلك من الجيد ان
يعود الوضع الى ما هو مقبول على المستوى
الدولي في النيجر الشعب في النيجر يختار
القاده ولا يفرض القاده عبر انقلاب عسكري
ان المهام العسكريه تق بالدفاعي عن
السياده الوطنيه وعن اراضي البلاد ولكنه
لا يتعين عليهم ان ينقلبوا المنتخبون هم
من يحكم البلاد ولكن لسوء الحظ السياسيون
لم يتصرفوا دائما بطريقه مناسبه في بعض
الاحيان يغيرون الدساتير ويعدلون فيها وفي
احيان اخرى يقولون او يتقدمون بالوعود
ولكنهم لا ينفذون هذه الوعود هناك مشكله
مرتبطه بالجانب الامني
المعذره الارضيه المشتركه التي تشير اليها
نسال عنها الدكتور علي ابو بكر اماده هل
يمكن لقاده الانقلاب ان يقبلوا بارضيه
مشتركه لبدء الحوار وايجاد تسويه ما
ان
في داخل النيره في داخل النيجر اما هؤلاء
وكمان تعرفون الخطوط الجويه كلها مغلقه
هذا هذا هو هو الاشكال وحتى
هذا الحوار الذي دار بين الامريكان
اظن انها يعني جاءت بنتيجه الطيبه
في هذه الحاله سيد
اذا كان الحوار مؤجل في انتظار ان تقبل
النيجر باستقبال وفد الاكواس والامم
المتحده
ماذا ستفعل للاكواس
كما تعرفون ان قاده المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غرب افريقيا سوف يلتقون في بوجا يوم
الخميس لمراجعه الوضع وهناك
نيه حسنه حاولوا ان يعملوا مع الامم
المتحده ومع الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل
ارسال وفد للتفاوض مع القاده العسكريين في
النيجر ولكن لسوء الحظ يقول النظام الحالي
في النيجر انه بسبب العقوبات المفروضه من
قبل المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
هذا الوفد غير مرحب به ولكن ارى ان
المرونه ضروريه الجيش لا يمكنه ان يخوض
الحر طبعا هناك دول عبرت عن دعمها للقاده
العسكريين ولكن
هذه الامور التي تحصل في النيجر المخطئه
ويجب النظر بذلك في خلال المفاوضات اعتقد
ان الطرفين يتعين عليهما ان يلتقي في
مساحه مشتركه في وسط الطريق اذن بنسبه الى
عوده او حاله
الرئيس بزوم وعائلته والمسؤولين السياسيين
هذا امر ايضا يطرح في خلال هذه المفاوضات
لربما من خلال المفاوضات في قنوات خلفيه
خلف الكواليس ويتم تحديد النقاط ما يمكن
تقديمه من جهه وما يمكن تقديره من جهه
اخرى في المقابل اذا دائما يجب التوصل الى
تنازلات من كلا الطرفين شكرا لضيفينا سيد
بول من ابوجاه والدكتور علي ابو بكر امادو
من يامي
بعد يومين من انقضاء مهله اكواس لقاده
الانقلاب في النيجر يسلط تقرير لوكاله
رويتر الضوء على الخيارات امام مجموعه
اكواس وحلفائها من [__] الانقلاب
ياتي في المقدمه التدخل العسكري المباشر
لكن الثمه عوائق بحسب خبراء ابرزها انقسام
الدول اكواس ومخاوف التحول للصراع طويل
الامد ينعكس على استقرار المنطقه للنيجر
وحدها في المقابل يتوقع ان يؤثر عدم
التدخل على مصداقيه اكواس يشير السيناريو
الثاني الى تدخل قوه بريه محدوده تستولي
على المواقع الهامه وتحرر بازوم بدعم
استخباري غربي ويراه مراقبون خيارا واقعيا
لكنه قد يصطدم برد شعبي غاضب بالنظر لحجم
التظاهرات التي خرجت تاييدا للانقلاب
يتوقع محللون مختصون ايضا اللجوء
للسيناريو انقلاب مضاد استغلالا للتنوع
العرقي الواسع فضلا عن الانقسام الذي
يلاحظه محللون امنيون بين القوات المسلحه
الخيار الرابع يتمثل في الابقاء على
العقوبات الاقتصاديه مع استمرار المطالبه
بعوده الحكم المدني بعد الانتخابات لم
يرفض ق اده الانقلاب مناقشه ذلك ولكن تكمن
مخاطر هذا السيناريو في التخوف من تزايد
تراجع النيجر اقتصاديا ما قد يزيد رجحان
كفه قاده الانقلاب
قالت نائبه المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه صابرينا سينج انه لا وجود
لمؤشرات على ضلوع مجموعه في احداث النيجر
او توفيرها مساعدات هناك واكدت سنك في
احاطه صحفيه تجميد واشنطن بشكل مؤقت بعد
جهود التعاون الامني مع النيجر وتعليق
التدريبات العسكريه مشيره الى رغبه بلادها
برؤيه حل سلمي عبر الوسائل الدبلوماسيه
للوضع في النيجر
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيوم ان لقاء المبعوثه فيكتوريا نولاند
معقده الجيش في النيجر كان صعبا للغايه
وليس واضحا ما اذا كان قاده الانقلاب
سيختارون المسار الدبلوماسيه واضاف ميلر
في مؤتمر صحفي ان واشنطن تامل العوده على
الانقلاب لكنها بنفس الوقت تنتظر بواقعيه
او تنظر بواقعيه بالاحرى الى التطورات
هناك
مازال لدينا امل لكننا ايضا نتحلى
بالواقعيه بالنظر الى الاتصالات التي
اجرتها نولاند مع قاده الانقلاب والتي
قالت انها كانت صعبه للغايه يحدون الامل
بان تعود الامور الى ما كانت عليه ولكننا
في الوقت نفسه كنا واضحين تماما من خلال
اتصالاتنا المباشره مع قاده المجلس
العسكري بشان عواقب عدم العوده الى النظام
الدستوري
كما اكد ميلر ان المبعوث انولاند استمعت
خلال لقائها بالمجتمع المدني في النيجر
بانهم يدعمون عوده النظام الدستوري مشيرا
الى ان المظاهرات الداعمه للمجلس العسكري
بالشوارع لا تعبر بالضروره عن راي الشعب
النيجيري
في تلك الاجتماعات استمعت وكيله وزاره
الخارجيه الى قاده المجتمع المدني
والمنظمات الاهليه الذين عبروا عن قلقهم
العميق ومخاوفهم بشان الاوضاع وكذلك
رغبتهم بعوده النظام الدستوري الى البلاد
احببت ان اتحدث بهذا الامر لاني تلقيت
اسئله كثيره بشان التظاهرات والاحتجاجات
التي خرجت الى الشوارع لا اعتقد انه من
الانصاف القول بان كل من يدعم الديمقراطيه
يمكن ان يخرج متظاهرا الى الشارع خوفا على
سلامته ولكن كما قلت هي استمعت خلال
لقائها بالمجتمع المدني بانهم يدعمون عوده
النظام الدستوري ونحن ايضا ندعم ذلك
لاحقا في فتره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
اهميه النيجر الامنيه وشيرو سياسيه
بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده ونسال
السفيره الامريكيه السابقه في نيامي عن
خيارات واشنطن في التعامل مع هذه الازمه
انا مراسل الجزيره ان الطائرات الحربيه
التابعه للجيش السوداني قصفت مواقع للدعم
السريع حول المدينه الرياضيه الجنوبيه
الخرطوم وذكرت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان
الجيش وجه قصفا مدفعيا متتاليا استهدف
مواقع الدعم السريع في احياء بري والمنشيه
والمعموره والرياض شرقي الخرطوم هذا
واستمرت المواجهات بين طرفي الازمه في
منطقه السوق الشعبي وحول مقر قوات
الاحتياط المركزيه التابعه للشرطه يتزامن
ذلك مع تحليق مكثف لطائرات الجيش في سماء
وسط ام درمان وحي ابروف
والقماير شرقيه ام درمان
وردت عليها قوات الدعم السريع بالمضادات
الارضيه
قالت قوات العمل الخاصه تابعه للجيش
السوداني انها كبدت الدعم السريع خسائر في
الاليات القتاليه وانها تمكنت من السيطره
على مقر ما وصفتهم بالمليشيات المتمرده في
حي الدوحه يوم درمان في معركه دارت منذ
صباح اليوم وقال بيان للجيش السوداني ان
قوته كبدت قوات الدعم مئات القتلى والجرحى
في معارك ام درمان اليوم
ومشطت عده احياء في المدينه مشيرا الى ان
قوته اكملت مهامها المخططه بنجاح على حد
تعبيره
في المقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع انها
حققت ما سمته نصرا جديدا على قوات الجيش
في عده محاور بام درمان وذكر بيان للدعم
السريع ان قوتهم قتلت 174 من الجيش واصابه
نحو 300 اخرين كما تم اسر 83 اسيرا في
المعارك التي جرت بين الجانبين بعده احياء
في ام درمان بالخرطوم
وقد تصدرت تطوراته في ام درنان اخبار
المشهد السوداني خلال هذه الايام مع
اشتداد المعارك في جبهات مختلفه بدات
الجسور الرابطه بينها ومدن العاصمه
السودانيه المثلثه
رهانا يحاول كل من الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع كسبه لتعزيز مواقعه او الحفاظ
عليها نتعرف اكثر على طبيعه ما يحدث في
يوم درمان
مدينه ام درمان تشكل الجزء الكبير من
الخرطوم عاصمه البلاد وتقع على طول الضفه
الغربيه لكل من نهر النيل ونيل الابيض
قباله مدينه الخرطوم ومدينه الخرطوم بحري
لها اهميه عسكريه استراتيجيه لطرفي القتال
فهي تضم مواقع عسكريه مهمه في مقدمتها مقر
سلاح المهندسين وهو من المواقع الحصينه
للجيش السوداني كما توجد في شمالها قواعد
عسكريه في كرري ووادي سيدنا تابعه للجيش
مما يمنحه السيطره على مداخل ومخارج
المدينه من جهه الشمال فيما تسيطر قوه
الدعم السريع على اجزاء في غرب وجنوب
المدينه حيث معسكر صالحه وتعتبر نقاط
تمركزها مواقع تلتقي فيها خطوط الامدادات
القادمه من الغرب الى العاصمه منذ ايام
احتدمت وتيره القتال في ام درمان وعوده
الاعنف وتركزت في ابروف والجماير وامتدت
حتى السوق الشعبي ومحيط مقر القوات
الاحتياطيه المركزيه التابعه للشرطه
استخدمت الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه حيث
اشار الجيش السوداني لقصف مواقع للدعم
السريع في جنوب المدينه مع تحليق لطيران
الحربي ورد من مضادات ارضيه لدعم السريع
اشتباكات وصفت بالاعنف ودارت في منطقه
استراتيجيه تحيط بمركزين رئيسيين هما مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون لكنها ايضا لا تبعد عن
جسر شنبات الذي تسيطر عليه قوه الدعم
السريع ويعتبر منفذها الاوحد في عمليه نقل
الجنود والمعدات والعتاد والجسر الثاني
الذي يكتسي اهميه هو جسر الحلفايه ويربط
ام درمان بالخرطوم بحري بطول يتجاوز 900
متر وبعرض 27 مترا ويمكنه استيعاب سته
ممرات يسيطر الجيش على مدخله من الغرب
بينما الدعم السريع من الشرق واهميته في
اتاحه المرور من خلاله باطراف مدينه ام
درمان ومن جهه ام درمان للوصول الى قاعده
وادي سيدنا الجويه والكليه الحربيه
الشماليه الع اصمه من التطورات بدات
استراتيجيه الجيش في تقطيع الاوساط
والسيطره على نقاط التواصل بين قوه الدعم
السريع في مدن العاصمه المثلثه ويبدو
التصعيد في ام درمان عنوانا لذلك
ومعنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديميه السوداني اهلا وسهلا بك
هل نحن امام بعض التطور النوعي في سير
المعارك
اليوم بالذات يعني يمثل اول معركه
بمتحرك متكامل يخوض الجيش خارج معسكراته
الاساسي الاساسيه الطوال الفتره الماضيه
كان الجيش في حاله دفاع وكان في توسيع
نطاق التامين وفي عمليات خاصه اليوم يعني
تغيرت المعادله الدعم السريع منذ فتره
اوقف الهجوم يعني تم استنزافه بشكل كبير
وتحول من الهجوم على الجيش الى حاله من
الدفاع داخل الخرطوم يعني خصوصا انه
تواترت انباء من مستشارين وفي الخارج يعني
صحيحه ام كاذبه المهم كثر الحديث حول
مفاوضات ومساومات وحلول عبر المفاوضات
فبعد ان حصل كبير لقوه الدعم السريع داخل
الخرطوم تحولت الى الدفاع وهذا تغيير
برايك ليس مؤقتا ليس مؤقتا يعني حصل لها
استنزاف كبير يعني حصل استنزاف في قوات
النخبه المدربه حصل استنزاف في عربات
الدفع الرباعي في المدافع ذات الكثافه
النيرانيه العاليه في الافراد نفسهم تم
استعراض افراد يعني كان هنالك افراد
يدخلون الى الخرطوم لكن هذه الذين دخلوا
للخرطوم ليسوا مدربين مثل قوات النخبه
التي بدات الحرب فكان لابد من تغيير سياسه
يعني فشلوا في في كل معسكرات الجيش
الاساسيه فشله في الاستيلاء عليها خصوصا
القياده ووادي سيدنا العسكريه باعتبار انه
الطيران فيها والمهندسين والمدرعات ولكن
حتى الجيش يكابد في
تحقيق بعض المنجزات على حساب الدعم
السريعي يعني
ليس ليس متقدما بسهوله وهو الجيش لم يبدا
مرحله الانقضاض يعني هذه المعركه هي معركه
انهاك استنزاف ثم انقضاض لكن قبل مرحله
الانقباض هذه الجيش يعمل على الوصول الى
نقاط حاكمه تفصل قوات الدعم السريع عن
بعضها وتشل حركتها لانه قوات الدعم السريه
تعمل باستراتيجيه الفزع بمعنى انه اذا حصل
عليها هجوم في مكان ما يتحرك كل قواتها
بسرعه هي دعم سريع فتتحرك بسرعه جدا
للهجوم في مناطق في في المنطقه المعينه
اليوم ظهرت خطه الجيش بالهجوم باكثر من
محور في اكثر من منطقه فشلت
الدعم السريع من انه يجمع قواته في فزع
للوصول
والمؤسف في كل هذا يعني حسب منظمه انسانيه
انه للاسف بعض الجثث في يعني تحللت يعني
لم يستطيعوا حتى
اخذها في الخرطوم التكلفه الانسانيه عاليه
جدا التكلفه الانسانيه في الانسان
السوداني ايا كان موقف من هذه الحرب عاليه
جدا تكلفه في البنيات الاساسيه تكلفه في
بنيات الدوله الاساسيه في الخدمات
الاساسيه لانسان السودان بالاضافه الى
التكلفه البشريه العاليه هذه تكلفه لن
تعوض بسهوله شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور اسامه
عيدروس على حضورك معنا شكرا لك
ونبقى في السودان فقد اصدر والي القضارف
فالمكلف محمد عبد الرحمن محجوب امرا بفرض
حاله طوارئ بالولايه يشمل منع كافه
التجمعات ايا كانت اسبابها الا باذن من
السلطات الامنيه وذلك حفاظا على سلامه
وامن سكان الولايه وفق نص الامر واعلن
الوالي اغلاق كافه المعابر الحدوديه مع
دول الجوار ومنع دخول الاجانب الا ما
تقرره السلطات القوميه لاستقبال
السودانيين العالقين بالخارج او السماحل
الاجانب بمغادره البلاد
قال فرحان حقا نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده انه وكاله اللاجئين
تحذر من تدهور الاوضاع الصحيه في السودان
بما في ذلك في مخيمات اللاجئين ومراكز
العبور واضاف حق ان اكثر من اربعه ملايين
شخص اجبروا على الفرار داخل السودان
والبلدان المجاوره منذ بدء الاشتباكات
المسلحه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده للشؤون
اللاجئين من تدهور الاوضاع الصحيه في جميع
انحاء السودان بما في ذلك بمخيمات
اللاجئين ومراكز العبور اجبر اكثر من
اربعه ملايين شخص على الفرار داخل السودان
والى البلدان المجاوره منذ بدل اعمال
العدائيه الحاليه ونزح اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين ومئتي الف شخص داخل السودان بينهم
اكثر من 187 الف لاجئ
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اكد
الجيش الاوكراني ان قوته نفذت عمليه خاصه
في معقل القوات الروسيه بالضفه الجنوبيه
لنهر ودمرت مركزا للقياده الروسيه بها في
المقابل اعلنت القوات البوليه لروسيا في
خرسون افشالها للعمليه الاوكرانيه
تخرج المعارك عن جبهاتها المعتاده وتتحرك
نحو الجنوب في خرسون وعبر نهر النيبر في
عمليه وصفها الجيش الاوكراني بالخاصه
والنوعيه وهي عمليه انزال عسكري على الضفه
الجنوبيه للنهر الذي يشكل حاجزا طبيعيا
بين قوات البلدين يقول الجيش الاوكراني ان
قواته نفذت عمليه خاصه في معقل القوات
الروسيه بالمنطقه ودمرت مركز للقياده
الروسيه هناك ما اسفر عن مقتل عدد كبير من
الجنود الروس في المقابل اعلنت القوات
المواليه لروسيا في خرسون انها افشلت هذا
الانزال بينما اشار الجيش الروسي الى
استهداف مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب جسر
اندونيسكي بعد حصوله على ما قال انها
معلومات استطلاعيه في الجنوب ايضا قال
الجيش الاوكراني ان الاسطول الروسي يشهد
حاله اضطراب بعد الاستهدافات الاخيره وان
موسكو تنشر 10 سفن في البحر الاسود لكن
ليس حاملات الصواريخ محبرا مع ذلك من ان
خطر الهجوم الصاروخي الروسي ما زال مرتفعا
وعوده الى الجبهات الشرقيه قال الجيش
الروسي من جهته انه احبط محاولات هجوميه
للقوات الاوكرانيه فيسك واكد ان الطيران
الحربي نفذ ضربات على اهداف اوكرانيه في
خمسه اتجاهات ابرزها
من جهه اخرى تتوالى مشاهد قصف مواقع بها
مدنيون اخرها اصابه طفل جراء القصف
الاوكراني على دير القديس جورنالز في
مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه المحاميه للحدود مع
اوكرانيا حسب مشاهد نشرتها وكاله تاسا
الروسيه وياتي ذلك في وقت تحتدم فيه
الاتهامات بين الطرفين في استهداف
المدنيين
قالت نتاليا هم نيويورك المتحدثه باسم
قيادات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تتحرك بما يضمن لها
التقدم خلال المعارك الدائره بجنوب
اوكرانيا
في هذه المرحله نحن نقوم بالتقدم بناء على
ما لدينا من قوات وعلى الترتيبات المناسبه
والمريحه لنا نحن نحافظ على قواتنا وعلى
جنودنا وهذه هي القيمه الاعلى بالنسبه لنا
اما الهدف الاخر فهو تقدم قواتنا وفرض
الخروج من مناطقنا على العدو
في المقابل القاره المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
ان القوات الروسيه استهدفت مقرا للقياده
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الموحده في بروجرافس
في منطقه بدونيت استهدفنا مركز القياده
المتقدم للمجموعه الموحده للقوات
الاوكرانيه كما تم تدمير ثلاثه مستودعات
ذخيره للمدفعيه قرب مدينه زبوروجيا وفي
مناطقيف وفي اتجاه كوبيانسك سيطرت قواتنا
على مواقع مهمه بالقرب من قريه اورشانا
بخار كيف ونجح الدفاعاتنا في صد تسع هجمات
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مناطق بلوغانسك
معنا من عمان اللي هو فايز الدويريا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا
بك
حضره اللواء ما زلنا في نفس الدائره كل
طرف يزعم انه يحقق تقدما في حين اننا لا
نعلم بالضبط الصوره النهائيه
يعني منذ عده اسابيع لا يوجد معارك حاسمه
لا يوجد معارك حقيقيه
يوجد اشتباكات محدوده قد تكون اليد العليا
في جنوب باخموت للقوات الاوكرانيه اليد
العليا في شرق الايمان للقوات الروسيه لكن
كلا الجانبين لا يحقق انجازات حقيقيه على
الارض لهذا السبب تجد معظم التصريحات
والحديث يدور حول عمليات القصف والقصف
المضاد سواء بالطائرات المسيره او
بالصواريخ كما تم الحديث وعاشرت انت له عن
عمليه
عبور نهر الدينيبر القوات الاوكرانيه تقول
نفذنا عمليه القوات الروسيه تقول افشلنا
العمليه هذا ماذا يعطي يعطي مؤشر على انها
عمليه محدوده صغيره جدا
توصف بعمليات الاغاره على اهداف محدده
وبالتالي قد تنجح في اداء مهمتها وقد يتم
احباطها وفي المشكله الحقيقيه ان الحقيقه
هي الضحيه لان البيانات متعارضه ولابد من
مرور ساعات او ايام حتى يتم الحديث
والتصريح بناء على تقارير حقيقيه من جهه
محايده لكن دعني اقول اصبحنا الان كان
عطرفي القتال كانهم يخوضوا حرب استنزاف
لان كلا الجانبين لا يملك القدره على
تطوير ادائه الميداني خاصه الجانب
الاوكراني لماذا لان المناطق التي تعتبر
منطلق لعمليات مستقبليه ناجحه باتجاه
القرم او بحر اسوف او مولوتوبر اوتوكماك
تواجه معضله حقيقيه في اختراق الجدار
الدفاعي ثلاث ثلاثه انظمه او احزمه دفاعيه
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال القتال في الحزام
الاول كذلك للجانب الروسي يحاول ان يحقق
انجازات في منطقه ليمان لكن يبدو قدرات
الميدانيه لا تؤهل هذه القوات على تحقيق
انجازات كبيره فكاننا كان القتال بدا
الدخول مرحله حرب الاستنزاف الا اذا جد
امر طارئ
لاي من الجانبين شكرا لك وفايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اتهمت كيبل القوات الروسيه بقصف مبالا
سكنيه في بوكرفسك بمقاطعه دوناتش الشرقيه
البلاد ما ادى الى مقتل سبعه اشخاص واصابه
اخرين مشيرا مشيره الى ان القوات الروسيه
عاودت قصف المنطقه بصاروخ من طراز اسكندر
اثناء اجلاء المصابين
على واقع اليم سقط عشرات القتلى والجرحى
جراء قصف صاروخيا روسي استهدف وسط هذه
المدينه وتحديدا المنطقه السكنيه التي
يمكن ان نشاهدها
الذي حصل هنا سقط الصاروخ الاول في ساعات
المساء وقتل على اثره شخص واصيب اكثر من
سبعه بجراح عندما وصلت فرق الانقاذ الى
هذه المنطقه تحديدا وبشرت عمليات ازاله
الركام ومحاوله انقاص واخراج الجرحى
والمصابين والضحايا سقط صاروخ ثان مما ادى
الى مقتل واصابه العشرات يمكن ان نشاهد
حجم الدمار الذي خلفه الصاروخ الثاني في
هذا المبنى وهو فندق في وسط المدينه
الاضرار التي اصابت
منازلهم ومساكنهم وقد بات القصف يتكرر
بشكل دائم في كل هذه المناطق الواقعه في
مقاطعه دونيتس مسجد ابراهيم الجزيره
بوكوروس اوكرانيا
قررت لجنه الانتخابات الباكستانيه منع
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان من ممارسه
العمل السياسي لمده خمس سنوات بعد اذاناته
بتهم فساد وتمنع القوانين في باكستان اي
شخص تثبت ادانته من الترشح لاي منصب عمومي
لفتره تحددها لجنه الانتخابات وكان محامي
عمران خان قد قال ان موكله طعن اليوم على
ادانته والحكم بسجنه ثلاث سنوات واضاف
المحامي ان الطعنه على الحكم الصادر في
مطلع الاسبوع قدم الى المحكمه العليا التي
ستنظر فيه يوم غد الاربعاء
هدد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوئاف جالنت
اليوم باعاده لبنان الى العصر الحجري وذلك
في اي حرب تدخلها مع حزب الله
خلال زيارته الحدود الشماليه مع لبنان انه
في حال اندلعت مواجهه فان اسرائيل لن
تتورع عن استخدام كل قوتها
نحن نتدلع جينا نعرف كيف نحمي دوله
اسرائيل ومواطنيها في كل الاحوال على
العدو ان يفهم انه عندما يدور الحديث عن
امن اسرائيل فكلنا موحدون احذر حزب الله
ونصر الله الا يرتكب خطا لقد ارتكبتم
اخطاء في الماضي ودفعتم ثمنها باهظا واذا
حدث اي تصعيد او اندلعت اي مواجهه سنعيد
لبنان الى العصر الحجري لن نتردد عن
استخدام كل قوتنا وسحق كل متر تابع لحزب
الله ولبنان اذا تطلب الامر لا ترتكب
الاخطاء ولا نريد حربا لكننا جاهزون
للدفاع عن المواطنين وجنودنا وسيادتنا
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعد سيناريو
لحرب محتمله مع حزب الله كشفت عنه صحيفه
اسرائيل اليوم ويتوقع الجيش الاسرائيلي في
هذا السيناريو ان يطلق حزب الله ما معدله
سته الاف صاروخ يوميا خلال ايام الحرب
الاولى ليتراجع العدد الى ما بين 1500
بعد بضعه اياما من بدء هذه الحرب ويتوقع
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان تتوسع رقعه الحرب
لتشمل قطاع غزه كذلك الذي ستنطلق منه
صواريخ باتجاه اهدافا اسرائيليه اضافه الى
توقعات بان يقتل خمسمائه مدني اسرائيلي
والاف الجرحى وهذه الارقام لا تشمل
العسكريين كما توقع الجيش ان يواجه صعوبات
في حمايه المواقع الحساسه التي ستكون هدفا
للقصف مثل المحطات الكهرباء والمصانع
ومراكز التموين
وقد نظم الجيش اللبناني جوله ميدانيه
للسفراء وممثلين الدول الاعضاء في مجلس
الامن الدولي المعتمدين في بيروت على طول
الحدود اللبنانيه وقدم منسق الحكومه
اللبنانيه لدى قوات الامم المتحده خلال
هذه الجوله شرحا على النقاط المتنازع
عليها مع اسرائيل عند الخط الازرق وكانت
الامم المتحده قد رسمت هذا الخط للفصل بين
الجانبين بعد الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من جنوب
لبنان عام 2000 ويتحفظ لبنان على 13 نقطه
عندها الخط
نحن في اخر نقطه حدوديه بريه بين لبنان
وشمال اسرائيل وتحديدا قرب النفق الذي كان
انشاه الاستعمار لبريطانيا والفرنسي
قبل نشوء دوله اسرائيل المنطقه الحدوديه
البريه بالنسبه للبنان تنطلق من نقطه
معروفه باسم
الحدود البحريه هذه زوارقه اسرائيليه
عمليا تراقب الجوله الصحفيين التي نظمها
الجيش اللبناني وهي منطقه تعتبرها اسرائيل
منطقه
اقليميه لها الحدود البحريه
هي منطقه ايضا عوامات بحريه لم يجري
ترسيمها بعد بسبب الخلاف على انطلاق
النقطه البريه لكن لبنان توصل الى اتفاق
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي ببساطه امريكيه
لترسيم الحدود المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه
التي تبعد عده كيلومترات من النقطه التي
نقف فيها والتي من المفترض ان يبدا فيها
التنقيب عن الغاز والنفط بحلول نهايه اب
اغسطس الحالي وفق ما اعلنت وزاره الطاقه
اللبنانيه الجيش اللبناني يريد تثبيت مبدا
من خلال هذه الجوله بان لبنان لديه نقاط
متحفظ عليها على طول الحدود البريه وايضا
اسرائيل تحاول فرض امر واقع في هذه
المنطقه ويريد شرح الامر لاعضاء مجلس
الامن الدولي في كل التفاصيل الميدانيه
على الارض لتثبيت حقوق لبنان لبنان يعتبر
ان الحدود البريه معترف بها منذ عام
1923 وان اسرائيل
تختبئ خلف الخط الازرق الذي يعد خط انسحاب
وليس خطا للحدود الرسميه اللبنانيه وفقه
ما يقول الجيش اللبناني ايهاب العقدي
الجزيره راس الناقوره جنوب لبنى
في المتابعه الليله نعيد فتح ملف التطورات
في النيجر لكن هذه المره من زاويه العلاقه
بين هذا البلد الافريقي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بما فيها من تشابك للمصالح
الولايات المتحده المانيحه الرئيسيه
للمساعدات الانسانيه والامنيه للنيجر
ويقدر حجم المساعدات التي تم تعليق جزء
منها اخيرا بمئات الملايين من الدولارات
في الشرق الامني والعسكري ترى واشنطن في
نيامي شريك رئيسيا في محاربه الجماعات
المتطرفه في منطقه الساحل جنوب الصحراء
وشمالها وتحتفظ واشنطن بوجود عسكري على
اراضي النيجر قوامه الف ومئه جندي يعملون
رسميا ضمن برنامجا لتدريب قوات النخبه في
جيش النيجر وتاهيلها لدعم جهود الامن
الاقليمي اغلب الجنود الامريكيين في
النيجر هم من القوات الخاصه وينتشر جزء
كبير منهم في الشطر العسكري من مطار
العاصمه نيامي كما ان واشنطن
لواشنطن قاعده جويه استطلاعيه للطائرات
المسيره في ضواحي مدينه اكاديس شماليه
البلاد قرب الحدود الليبيه والجز ويطلق
عليها اسم القاعده اي بي 200 وواحد تدرك
الولايات المتحده ان مصالحها الاستراتيجيه
في افريقيا تمر عبر النيجر غير ان اطاحه
حليفها هناك الرئيس محمد بازون وضع
العلاقه بين البلدين على اعتاب مرحله
جديده
اثاره اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدون
تدعم اعاده رئيس النيجر المنتخب ديمقراطيا
الى السلطه لكنها تتجنب مع ذلك وصف عزله
بانهم كلاب
يعود ذلك في جانب منه الى ان قانون
التخصيصات الامريكيه يحد بشده من
المساعدات الخارجيه للجيوش في حاله
اقدامها على اطاحه حكومات مدنيه
في الجانب العسكري تؤكد السلطات الامريكيه
انها لا تخطط حاليا لسحب قواتها من النيجر
وتقول انها لم تتلقى طلبات بهذا الشان
وتبدي دوائر القرار في واشنطن مخاوف من
تاثير تغيير النظام في النيجر على ما
تسميها الجهود الغربيه
لمكافحه الارهاب في منطقه الساحل الغربي
افريقيا تنضم الينا الان من ميريلاندا
السيده فيزا ويليامز السفير الامريكيه
السابقه في النيجر
ونائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق للشؤون الافريقيه اهلا وسهلا بك
السيده ويليامز هل تبدو الولايات المتحده
في حيره في التعامل مع ملف النيجر الان
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه الكريمه الليله
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت واضحه في
موقفها خصوصا مع ارسال المسؤوله في وزاره
الخارجيه الى النيجر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تود ان ترى الرئيس بازوم وقد
عاد الى سته الرئاسه في البلاد وتود ان
ترى النظام الدستوري يعود في البلاد ولكن
الاشكال هو كيف سيده
نعم كيف
بالفعل هذه هي الاشكاليه وهذا هو التحدي
بالفعل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يبدو
انها تود ان تستخدم كل الخيارات المطروحه
على المستوى الدبلوماسي تعمل على مستوى
المفاوضات الدبلوماسيه من خلال هذه الجهود
العملي مع المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا والاتحاد الافريقي للتفاوض مع
العسكريين
والعقوبات ايضا تؤدي الى معاناه الشعب في
النيجر والقوات المسلحه سوف تجد نفسها من
دون دعما اعتادت عليه في خلال السنوات
الماضيه في مكافحه الارهاب في تلك المنطقه
ولكن اليس غريبا سيد ويليام انه رغم كل
العلاقات العسكريه والامنيه بين الولايات
المتحده والنيجر تجد واشنطن الان صعوبه في
الحديث الى هؤلاء العسكريين
انت جد من الصعوبه الحديث مع هؤلاء
العسكريين في الحقيقه نعم الوكيل زارت
النيجر وصحيح كما تفضلتم لم تتمكن من لقاء
عبد الرحمن سياني وهو الرقم واحد في هذا
الانقلاب تمكنت من الاحاديث مع مسؤول اذا
كان مسؤولا عن القوات الخاصه النيجيريه في
الشمال ولديها علاقات جيده ووطيده مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلفاء
الولايات المتحده في مكافحه الارهاب
وبالتالي حقيقه انها التقت
بمسؤولا في هذا الانقلاب او المجموعه
الانقلابيه هو امرا يجب ان نسلط الضوء
عليه طبعا هناك تغير في المزاج بحسب فهمي
بين الفتره والاخرى عند شياني لا اعرف اذا
ما كان هذا هو السبب الذي منعه من لقاء
المبعوثه الامريكيه لست متاكده من السبب
ولكن حقيقه انها
ارتقت بالمسؤول هذا امر مهم هل تعتقدين
صيدليه بان احجام واشنطن على وصف ما جرى
بانه انقلاب ربما يعطي انطباع لهؤلاء
العسكريين بانه بامكانهم ان يفرضوا امرا
واقعا جديدا في البلاد
اعتقد ان هذا السؤال هو سؤال وجيه بالفعل
من جهه اذا ما ارادوا بالحقيقه ان ينظروا
باتجاه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ويقولوا على سبيل المثال نتحدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بان تتوقف عن دعمنا في
مجال مكافحه الارهاب هذا سوف يؤدي الى
تبعات من مثل فرد العقوبات الى اخره اذا
يمكن تفسير هذا الامر بطريقه التاليه ولكن
المبعوثه الامريكيه كانت واضحه في الموقف
الامريكي حاليا نعم الولايات المتحده
لديها مساعدات عسكريه ولكن ايضا مساعدات
تنمويه مع النيجر وعلاقات مع المجتمع
المدني ومع الشعوب ومع الشعب في النيجر
وعلاقات مع الاحزاب السياسيه من معارضه
ومن حكومه بال
اعتقد ان هذا الخوف بمحله بالنسبه الى
النفوذ الروسي بالتحديد لكي نكون محددين
بشكل اكبر نتحدث عن استخدام قوات فاغنر في
النيجر هناك فرق بين القول ان هناك قوات
سوف تصل الى المنطقه قوات فاجنر ومن جهه
والقول ان روسيا سوف يكون لديها نفوذ اذا
السؤال المباشر هل سوف تصل قوات الى هذه
البلاد وهل سوف تستخدم نفس التكتيكات
الكارثيه التي استخدمت في بلدان افريقيه
اخرى هذا هو مبعث القلق بالنسبه الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا يندرج في
السياق التنافس بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده ولكن هذا على الامد الابعد شكرا
السفيره
شكرا جزيلا لك
غابات الامازون هي اكبر غابه مطيره في
العالم تعتبر حوضا رئيسيا للكربون وتتميز
بامكانيه امتصاص كميات ضخمه من ثاني اكسيد
الكربون وهي وظيفه حاسمه كما نعلم في
المعركه الدوليه ضد تغير المناخ تضم نحو
10% من التنوع البيولوجي على الكوكب خلال
قمه بدات في البرازيل اليوم صدرت تعهدات
من نوع لا يمكننا السماح بوصول الامازون
الى نقطه العوده واذا تم الوصول فعلا الى
نقطه لا عوده فان الامازون ستصدر كميه من
الكربون اكثر مما تمتصه مما سيؤدي في
النهايه الى تفاقم ظاهره احترار الكوكب
الامل كل الامل فعلا ان يصبح هذا الاجتماع
نقطه تحول في تاريخ الدفاع عن الامازون
والغابه والتحول البيئي كما قال الرئيس
البرازيلي سيلفا قبل سعد
والا نصل الى نقطه لا عوده بعد سنوات من
الان ختام وحصائد هذه الليله في امان الله